when did jacksepticeye blow up everyone  thinks it's like the shout out was when  the channel blew up and like made the  whole Channel but that is kind of like a  misconception when the shout out  happened it got like I think it was like  15K subs or like 20K Subs in the first  two days and then it just stopped dead  but I think 2016 was when I had like the  biggest boom in my whole career when  will jacksept the guy upload again I  uploaded today go watch it when did  jacksepticeye dye his hair I think that  was 26 Mark was doing a sort of charity  event and he was talking about dying his  hair blue and I was like okay [ __ ] do  it I'll dye my hair green if you do it  I've had my hair brown longer than I've  had a green but for some reason people  think my hair has been green forever  there's far more gray in it than I would  like to admit but it's natural  you see that fake hair doesn't move like  that